man who founded megadeth and who ended  up unhappy because  he wasn't as popular as metallica i mean  he got trapped in a very unlikely  situation because he was staggeringly  successful but  unfortunately compared himself to a  group that was even more staggeringly  successful  reminded me of someone i knew once who  was upset about how much progress he had  made by the time he was 40  compared to his roommate in college  yeah and this person was a successful  serial entrepreneur and  and a mover and shaker in his own right  intellectually and practically but his  roommate was elon musk  and to some degree you have to write  that off as just bad  luck compare yourself to who you were  yesterday and not to some to who someone  else is today